um there's some there's some pretty good
ones especially you know one of the
crazy things when you do this live Q&A
is some of them are very silly so we got
one mark are the allegations true that
you're secretly a lizard I'm gonna have
to go with no on that I am NOT a lizard
but you know keep the high quality
comments coming in well where where
where where where where where
well mr. sucker dunked yourself into a
hole
mr. sucker not a lizard people he said
we've been seeing Mark Zuckerberg act
strange for a long time a long time now
from from the infamous or famous meme
nice job team
new face filters on Instagram today this
is my favorite one so far nice job team
new face filter an Instagram today this
is my favorite one so far nice job team
something is clearly off with Mark
Zuckerberg antics before where what is
it why is the man leading a social media
network so incapable of social this I
just want to warn you guys what I'm
about to show you next
might shock you it might suck to watch
especially for you mark if you're
watching I know you are I know you're
watching Martin well I know you're
sweating or can you sweat mark are you
capable of human things or do you just
shed your skin you kind of need to
remind yourself that you need to focus
and and try not to let stuff bother you
as much as possible but it is gonna
bother you because you're human and and
I was human I am human still
yeah let's keep watching
but um put it but I was just referring
to myself in the past um not that I was
not human I was just referring to myself
in now that sort of thing doesn't just
slip out of your tongue okay mark all
right I was human that just doesn't
happen normally okay you just don't you
just don't simply say stuff that you're
not supposed to say like horrific
offensive words that are genuinely
frowned upon by the entirety of
humankind accept them okay all right
well it just doesn't happen mark I need
answers but it is gonna bother you
because you're human and I was human I
am human still but they cut away to the
audience you know they they have his
drone sitting in the back Oh God Oh God
we got a cold right over here
what is it that you're hiding from us a
market suck why is your laptop webcam
taped over with your microphone is it so
that during your shedding period people
won't find out well I know because from
one reptile to another I mean from one
part I I know okay I just know I have
sources I have a reliable source assist
that's telling me that you're a wreck
time okay this is a really great channel
that analyzes body language let's see
what they have to say about the suck so
for me the thing that I was really
fascinated by it it always have been is
people right and how people work um
you notice we're gonna go back I didn't
expect it to cut off from his body you
see how he's sitting straight up hands
on his knees head up chin level where as
opposed to this guy who's mirroring mark
he slightly angled down in the face
so he's submitting to mark he's covering
he's open he's dominating the space and
he is purposely doing this and we'll
I'll show you how I know is people right
and how people work in orders in college
I studied psychology and computer
very long intense eye contact he's
purposely doing it looks away shortly
purposely doing that as well thoughts
come through it gives a break but is to
dominate and you know one of the things
that you learn when you study psychology
is that there are all these parts of the
brain which are geared say how long he's
holding that eye contact now normally
when you have someone who's submitting
to you and you're still continuously
dominating them in the fashion that he's
doing right now with his body posture
his intense eye contact you're going to
give them a break and relax your body so
that they can relax and be relaxed as
well so it's a relaxed atmosphere it
really feels like I'm I'm we're breaking
down and it's some sort of alien
life-form here okay that's been trained
to mimic human behavior a lot of stuff
along the way I think you know there
were real learning points and turning
and now we see the sweat and that's one
of the few things it's really hard to
control no no he doesn't sweat he
doesn't he doesn't sweat come on let's
get rid of him what's the holeczek thing
[Laughter]
well he's talking about oral sex
good morning Jarvis good morning mark
it's Saturday so you only have five
meetings room temperature is set to a
cool
68 degrees earlier this year I started
building a simple AI to help run our
home I talked to Jarvis using this app I
built it uses artificial intelligence to
understand me and figure out what to do
max woke up a few minutes ago I'm
entertaining her all right let's go
check on her practice our man Jarvis
your Mandarin is so soothing future
Jarvis also helps me get ready in the
morning fresh shirt Byron and whole hell
yeah and Jarvis can play all of our
favourite music hey play some good
Nickelback songs I'm sorry mark I'm
afraid I can't do that there are no good
Nickelback song good that was actually a
test all Nickelback sucks am i right
everyone yeah nickel bags is worst Oh
Nickelback sucks I hate them because
everyone else hate them have you heard
of my Crocs haha
for myself
anyway I talked to Jarvis using this app
I built it uses artificial intelligence
to understand and figure out what to do
Joris also helps me get ready in the
morning fresh shirt fire in the hole and
Jarvis can play all of our favorite
music okay how about just play some
songs that our whole family likes and if
I don't want to talk I could just text
Jarvis through a messenger bot that I
built my bad I think my favorite part of
mark is sense of humor it's truly
it's something hey welcome to f8 we're
gathered here at the second biggest
event called f8 this week and you know
we probably should have seen this one
coming out there probably should've seen
this coming after Fast and Furious 7
didn't it's our bad now while we don't
have the rock here today we do have the
tech equivalent David the rock Marcus
and while we may not live our lives a
quarter mile at a time
did you feel that that invokes some
something in me man what again while we
may not live our lives a quarter mile at
a time and we may not live our lives
one quarter life at a time man I know at
least some guy here lived their lives
one quarterly earnings at a time all
right
all right bear with me I got one more
one more for you no no no Zach I can't I
can't well fast and furious tagline is
never give up on family oh here it comes
or is it similar never give up on the
family of apps not as catchy not as
gadget oh my god
that has to be an inside joke please at
least let that be an inside joke oh my
god that's what progress in science is
so fast you might even call it fast and
furious
what's with the fast and furious
integration it's clearly sponsored is
suck himself hashtags spawn without
hashtag spawn mark you you you gotta you
got a hashtag spawn or hashtag add at
least I mean youth servers we're just
bombarded by this [ __ ] and and all the
shame and everything that comes with it
oh you had a promo and you didn't
disclose it with at least 48 hashtag ad
so look at the screen blasted with giant
symbols and the theme song of this is
Paul said this is sponsored I'm getting
paid for this what it what is happening
here okay but what what what kind of
world dominating plot are they working
on they're clearly doing in this at the
Oscar hey play some good Nickelback
songs Nickelback music is satanic one
like equals one prayer type payment in
the comments if you scroll down and
ignore you hate Jesus good that was
actually a test okay
how about just play some songs that our
whole family like they like you're
watching and remember one like equals
one suck